Speaker 1: Let's go to LJ from Las Vegas.
LJ, you are on the air.
Speaker 2: And David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine, sir.
Sure.
Speaker 2: How are you doing?
Good.
I'm doing called in a couple of times, so
I just want to give you a call back.
And I saw your video on YouTube, so I just
wanted to see if they get in.
Speaker 1: Well, we are here.
We are here.
Speaker 2: I just wanted something to kind
of give a comment to the last discussion you
had.
There's also another part of conspiracy theories
that we should also be aware of is never have
a conversation with about fire safety with
an arsonist.
So also depends on necessarily who's having
the discussion that where you would basically
have those discussions on conspiracy theories.
Speaker 1: That's a very good point.
Yeah.
And maybe to let go with the covid lab leak
stuff or whatever, like there's a big contingent
that is pro Trump who feel that if covid was
a bioweapon created in China, that would then
excuse Trump's total mishandling of the virus
like they have a political motivation.
Now, I simply disagree that it would, no matter
where covid came from, Trump mishandled it.
But they have a very particular interest in
pushing one narrative.
And so I think you're absolutely right that
we should we should consider the motivations
of people pushing certain ideas.
Speaker 2: So I actually am to discuss Trump
a little bit, I do feel that in the media
right now, at the moment, there seems to be
some kind of fanaticism with discussing everything
that he does, even though he's been removed
from Facebook, he's been removed from Twitter.
However, short term those removals are, there
seems to be like almost this scream that he
comes back.
So that way they can receive some more ratings
or higher, if you like, or watch time from
the audience is out there because he was so
good for them.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, I'd have I'd want to hear more about
who you think is hoping Trump comes back.
I actually am really worried that he comes
back.
Earlier this week, I did a segment explaining
I think that if there's a rematch of twenty,
twenty and twenty four, that it's very bad
for Joe Biden.
I have a really hard time believing that Joe
Biden is going to do well in a rematch against
Trump in twenty twenty four, for reasons I
laid out.
If Joe Biden says I'm not running and it's
kind of handed to Comilla, I think that that
would be really tough if Trump runs.
So I'm actually I'm hoping the opposite.
You know, I've said before in terms of my
level of coverage, this guy has done things
that arguably should should have gotten him
arrested at minimum.
And he he has lost almost no support from
the Republican Party.
That's really scary.
That's that's a problem with American culture
right now.
And so I'm covering him to the extent that
I do because he's relevant and he may be the
kingmaker in twenty two and he may run in
twenty four.
And if he runs, I think it's conceivable that
he will win.
But in terms of ratings, I mean I'm more concerned
with what's good for the country and Trump
coming back would be very bad for the country.
So I don't want it.
Speaker 2: Oh, absolutely, I completely agree.
It just it seems like and, you know, Fox News
already covers them all the time, right?
That's not the issue I'm talking about.
I just I feel like when he puts out one of
his long form tweets, the presidential releases,
whatever they're called, right?
Yep.
It's there's a romanticism that people say
it's like, oh, can you believe he's still
saying this?
I'm like, yes, he said it for four years.
You already know that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I agree with you.
Yeah.
And with those statements, I mean, we we've
basically started ignoring them when they're
relevant to something happening.
Bigger picture in the news.
We'll include it as part of a commentary.
But yeah, I mean, I think that there's some
channels where, like every day he's putting
one out and they're reading it and then doing
interviews on its basis.
That seems to me like maybe a little bit a
little bit over the line.
Speaker 2: Absolutely, so that's I just want
to comment on I love the show, have a great
day.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you very much.